Ken janpierre at the White House has
said that Joe Biden has stopped the flow
of foreigners illegal aliens into the
United States Eric Adams the New York
mayor is saying about these migrants uh
in New York City any plan that does not
include stopping the flow at the border
is a failed plan so why aren't you guys
stopping the flow at the border we are
stopping the flow at the border if
anything the what the president has been
able to do on his own without the help
of Republicans and Congress some that he
had to do on his own again because
Republicans refuse uh to give the
funding necessary to deal with a
situation uh imig a broken immigration
system that has been broken for decades
they choose what they choose to do is
play politics but the P the president
has put a plan that is indeed uh the
data showing is that it is indeed uh um
stopping slowing down the flow uh of
unlawful migration and that is because
of the work that this President
continues to do without without the help
of
Republicans what Karin jampier just said
is not true but there is a little tiny
kernel of Truth there and this is this
is the thing that the Liberals always do
here's how it's not
true since May there have been about
3600 illegal aliens crossing our
Southern
border illegally obviously every single
day
3,600 that does not sound like a stopped
flow of migration sounds like historic
highs I think the the exact number we're
down to now is about
3360 that's where they're obviously
there's significant
fluctuation now the reason that there's
a little tiny kernel of Truth in what
she's saying is back in March the number
was 7100 so there was this huge insane
surge in 30 30 3360 is it didn't say in
Surge 2 but this was double that
7,100 and then they got it down a little
bit so what Karine jeanpierre can say is
oh yeah we're stopping the flow we were
at 7100 a
day so we're talking millions and
millions and millions of illegal aliens
pouring across per year and now it's
down to only over 3,000 I remember just
a few years ago when we got up to 2,000
that was historic shocking
crisis but now they're saying 336 oh
that's pretty good that's stopping the
flow and this is what the Liberals
always do this is how they gain power
they take a lot and then they give back
a little
bit they take a lot and then they they
say okay we're going to we're going to
kill babies up until the moment of birth
and then okay we'll put some
restrictions in the third trimester
maybe in some places but probably not
even that oh good see we're winning
conservatives see look the Liberals are
moderating they're
compromising hey we're going to
everybody down to kindergarten okay
maybe just Middle School oh good we're
winning we're fighting back in the
culture what are you talking
about we started here you started on the
50 yard line liberals took this thing
all the way down to the end zone and
then we go back to what the 5 yard line
10 yard line okay well look we're
winning what we're not winning we're
getting crushed we're getting
destroyed but because they are so bold
in their aggression which conservatives
almost never are we're we're always
negotiating with ourselves
we're all we always listen to the the
squishes in the libs and the
establishment types who say well we
can't really we can't try to ban
abortion you know that's not where the
that's not where the voters are you know
oh yeah you think the voters were for
the kids no they weren't the Democrats
just took it and then they seeded a
little bit of territory back and then
that was The New
Normal well I don't I don't know this is
such a just tactically it's such a
stupid tactic anybody if you've ever
engaged in a job
negotiation or any kind of negotiation
you know never negotiate against
yourself always ask for the
most extreme thing that you could
plausibly get and then allow your
negotiation partner to pair you back a
little bit that's what the liberals do
that's not what we do we negotiate with
ourselves and we lose head on over to
helixsleep.com
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep that is why you need to
check out Helix mattress Helix has
harnessed years of extensive mattress
expertise to bring their customers a
truly elevated sleep experience they
just launched their new Helix Elite
collection which includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
preferences I've had my Helix for years
I absolutely love it night after night I
sleep like a sweet little child like
like an angel okay Helix has a sleep
quiz that matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else get out
of my mattress I'm a married man go to
helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz to find
the perfect mattress for your body and
sleep type their flexible payment plans
make it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20% off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners hurry on over to
helixsleep.com
withth Helix better sleep starts now now
speaking of
regression John Mel Camp just got into
trouble you know the musician John melan
Camp he was on Bill Mars Show and he
made an outrageous claim he said black
people are not better off today than
they were 200 years ago the playing
fields are a lot better than the cotton
fields that's what I would say about
that maybe I'm crazy John but it seems
like making no money as a slave picking
cotton was it was not as good as playing
left field for the Yankees I mean I'm
sure they were uh you know reasons why
Dave Windfield has some beeps against no
doubt there is one or
two% of black people in America who have
a better life oh stop that's what you
think one or two% okay let's say 10% I'm
just pulling a number out of my ass it
is out that's where it belongs he I just
pull a number out of my ass I know but
I'm telling you that's that's just not
true but you know well okay well I I
mean that's listen we do have statistics
talk to my talk talk to my son he'll
tell you well he saw one very horrific
incident maybe that has colored his
thinking what do you think that's so
incident that happens of course not so I
know you're going to look at this and
you're going to say bill mahs being the
more reasonable one here because John
melan Camp he's referring to some
incident of some black guy got beat up
or something and he's saying see this is
proof that the KKK runs around the
country and this is America's as bad as
it was under slavery or whatever and
Bill Mar says no I don't think so you
you know I think actually playing left
field for the Yankees is probably I'm
not saying it's perfect but it's
probably a little better than you know
working the cotton fields but in a way I
think I'm more on melan Camp's side here
when he says black people are not better
off than they were 200 years ago at
least let's say 150 years ago so we
don't have great statistics From Slavery
but after slavery we start to get some
relatively better numbers
and it's true that black people get a
higher wage than they did when they
didn't have a wage but here's just one
crucial statistic marriage rates
collapsed so there was very little legal
marriage among slaves under under
slavery Tennessee actually I think
allowed allowed marriage with between
slaves but it was very hard obviously
because if a slave gets sold down the
river then there goes the family the
family's broken up it's just absolutely
horrific so after slavery though you get
legal marriage and black people got
married at much higher rates and they
got divorced at much lower rates and
they had families in a much more stable
way today that has
collapsed that alone means black people
are not better off than they were 150
years ago that alone just that one
statistic and you see it among so many
other areas of society but just that one
statistic would do it see well they're
better off because they have more money
maybe yeah maybe that maybe they have
more money but money isn't everything
thing money isn't money is fine to have
I'm not opposed to it but it's not even
the primary thing and our society has
duped itself into thinking that that's
all that matters that's that's why we've
embraced globalism and liberalism and
materialism is because we think that
ticking up the GDP is all that matters
the Liberals have thought that and the
conservatives have thought that and so
we say well who cares if you lose your
borders and your culture and your
national identity and your religion and
who cares about that we're getting more
cheap crap from China and and we we have
more trade and look look at how the cost
of certain Goods has come
down some cases it's actually spiked up
because inflation's going crazy because
our economy is totally out of whack but
yeah okay also look at how our life
expectancy is gone down because people
are killing themselves and oding on
drugs look at how birth rates have
collapsed because people aren't getting
married and they are getting divorced
and they are using contraception and
they are killing their children through
abortion and they're doing all these
sorts of
things that mean that we are not we fool
ourselves in in a liberal Society we say
oh we're so much better off because we
have
iPhones we are worse off today by almost
every measure than we were 100 years ago
we have better dental care I guess
that's true I'm not saying we're worse
off in every
measure but if your Society is literally
dying and if the building block of
society is collapsing and has actually
been defined into nothingness in recent
years you cannot say with a straight
face that you're any better off than you
were 100 years ago in fact you are much
worse off man what a great clip that was
now make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time